[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
her mother shook her gently awake
coraline she said darling what a funny
place to fall asleep
and really this room was only for best
we looked
all over the house for you poor line
stretched and blinked
i'm sorry she said
it fell asleep i could see that said her
mother
and wherever did the cat come from he
was waiting by the front door when i
came in
shot out like a bullet as i opened it
probably had things to do said coraline
then she hugged her mother so tightly
that her arms began to ache her mother
hugged coraline back
dinner in 15 minutes said her mother
don't forget to wash your hands
and just look at those shakma bottoms
what did you do to your poor knee
i tripped said coraline she went into
the bathroom
and she washed her hands and cleaned her
bloody knee
she put ointment on her cuts and scrapes
she went into her bedroom
her real bedroom her true bedroom
she pushed her hands into the pockets of
her dressing gown
and she pulled out three marbles a stone
with a hole in it
a black key and an empty snow globe she
shook the snow globe and watched the
glittery snow
swirl through the water to fill the
empty world
she put it down and watched the snow
fall covering the place where the little
couple had once stood
coraline took a piece of string from her
toy box and she strung the black key on
the string
then she knotted the string and hung it
around her neck
there she said she put on some clothes
and hid the key under her t-shirt
it was cold against her skin the stone
went into her pocket
coraline walked down the hallway to her
father's study he had his back to her
but she knew just on seeing him
that his eyes when he turned around
would be her father's kind gray
eyes and she crept over and kissed him
on the back of his balding head
hello coraline he said and he looked
around and smiled at her
what was that for nothing said coraline
i just miss you sometimes that's all oh
so good he said he put the computer to
sleep
stood up and then for no reason at all
he picked coraline up
which he had not done for such a long
time
not since he had started pointing out to
her that she was much too
old to be carried and he carried her
into the kitchen
dinner that night was pizza and even
though it was homemade by her father
so the crust was alternately thick and
doughy and raw or too thin and burnt
and even though he put slices of green
pepper on it along with little meatballs
and of all things pineapple chunks
coraline ate the entire slice she had
been given
well she ate everything except for the
pineapple chunks
and soon enough it was bedtime coraline
kept the key around her neck but she put
the grey marbles beneath her pillow
and in bed that night coraline dreamed a
dream
she was at a picnic under an old oak
tree in a green meadow
the sun was high in the sky and while
there were distant
fluffy white clouds on the horizon the
sky above her head was a deep
untroubled blue there was a white linen
cloth laid on the grass
with balls piled high with food she
could see
salads and sandwiches nuts and fruit
jugs of homemade lemonade and water and
thick
chocolate milk coraline sat on one side
of this tablecloth
while three other children took a side
each they were dressed in the hottest
clothes
the smallest of them sitting on
coraline's left was a boy with red
velvet knee bridges and a frilly white
shirt
his face was dirty and he was piling his
plate high
with boiled new potatoes and with and
what looked like
cold whole cooked trout
this is the finest of picnic's lady he
said to her
yes said caroline i think it is
i wonder who organized it why i rather
think you did miss
said a tall girl sitting opposite
coraline she wore a brown
rather shapeless dress and had a brown
bonnet on her head which tied beneath
her chin
and we are more grateful for it and all
than ever words can say she was eating
slices of bread and jam deftly cutting
the bread from a large
golden brown loaf with a huge knife then
spooning on the purple jam with a wooden
spoon
she had jam all around her mouth i this
is the finest food i've eaten in
centuries said the girl on coraline's
right
she was a very pale child dressed in
what seemed to be spider's webs
with a circle of glittering silver set
in her blonde hair
coraline could have sworn that the girl
had two wings
like dusty silver butterfly wings but
not bird wings
coming out of her back the girl's plate
was piled high with pretty flowers
she smiled at coraline as if it had been
a very long time
since she had smiled and she had almost
but not quite
forgotten how coraline found herself
liking this girl immensely
and then in the way of dreams the picnic
was done
and they were playing in the meadow
running and shouting and tossing a
glittering ball from one to another
coraline knew it was a dream then
because none of them ever got tired or
winded or out of breath she wasn't even
sweating
they just laughed and ran in a game that
was partly tagged
partly piggy in the middle and partly
just a magnificent romp
three of them ran along the ground while
the pale girl flooded a little over
their heads
swooping down on butterfly wings to grab
the ball
and swing up again into the sky before
she tossed the ball to one of the other
children
and then without a word about it being
spoken the game was done
and the four of them went back to the
picnic cloth where the lunch dishes had
been cleared away
and there were four bowls waiting for
them three of ice cream
one of honeysuckle flowers piled high
they ate with
relish thank you for coming to my party
sid carline
if it is mine the pleasure is ours
coraline jones said the winged girl
nibbling another honeysuckle blossom
if there were but something we could do
for you to thank you and to reward you
i said the boy with the red velvet
bridges
and the dirty face he put out his hand
and held coraline's hand with his own
it was warm now it's a very fine thing
you did for us miss
said the tall girl she now had a smear
of chocolate ice cream all around her
lips
ah i'm just pleased it's all over said
carline
was it her imagination or did a shadow
cross the faces of the other children of
the picnic
the winged girl the circlet in her hair
glittering like a star
rested her fingers for a moment on the
back of coraline's hand
it is over and done with for us she said
this is our staging post from here
we three will set out for uncharted
lands and what comes
after no one alive can say
she stop talking
there's a but isn't there said coraline
i can feel it
like a rain cloud the boy on her left
tried to smile bravely but his lower lip
began to tremble and he bit it with his
upper teeth and said nothing
the girl in the brown bonnet shifted
uncomfortably and said
yes miss but i got you three back said
coraline
i got mom and dad back i shut the door i
locked it
what more was i meant to do the boy
squeezed coraline's hand with his
she found herself remembering when it
had been she trying to reassure him
when he was little more than a cold
memory in the darkness
well can you give me a clue ask coraline
isn't there something you can tell me
the beldum swore by her good right hand
said the tall girl
that she lied my governance said the boy
he used to say that nobody has ever
given more to shoulder than he or she
can bear
he shrugged as he said this as if he not
yet made up his
his own mind about whether or not it was
true
we wish you luck said the wicked girl
good fortune
and wisdom and courage although you have
already shown that you have all three of
these blessings
and in abundance she hates you
blurted out the boy she hasn't lost
anything for so long
be wise be brave
be tricky but it's not fair said
coraline in her dream angrily
it's just not fair ugh
it should be over the boy with the dirty
face stood up and hugged coraline
tightly
take comfort in this he whispered dart
alive
thou livest and in her dream coraline
saw that the sun had set
and the stars were twinkling in the
darkening sky
coraline stood in the meadow and she
watched as the three children two of
them walking
one flying went away from her across the
grass
silver in the light of the huge moon the
three of them came to a small wooden
bridge over a stream
they stopped there and turned and waved
and coraline waved back
and after when what came after was
darkness
coraline woke in the early hours of the
morning convinced she had heard
something moving
but unsure what it was she waited
made a rustling noise outside her
bedroom door
she wondered if it was a rat the door
rattled
coraline clambered out of bed go away
said coraline sharply go away or you'll
be sorry
there was a pause then the whatever was
scuttled away down the hall
there was something odd and irregular
about its footsteps
if they were footsteps coraline found
herself wondering if it was perhaps a
rat with an extra leg
it isn't over is it she said to herself
then she opened the bedroom door
the gray predawn light showed her the
whole of the corridor
completely deserted
she went towards the front door sparing
a hasty glance back at the wardrobe door
mirror hanging on the wall at the other
end of the hallway
seeing nothing but her own pale face
staring back at her
looking sleepy and serious gentle
reassuring snores came from her parents
room
but the door was closed
all the doors off the corridor were
closed whatever the scuttling thing was
it had to be here somewhere
coraline opened the front door and
looked at the gray sky
she wondered how long it would be until
the sun came up wondered whether her
dream had been a true thing
while knowing in her heart that it had
been something she had taken to be part
of the shadows under the hall couch
detached itself from beneath the couch
and made a mad
scrabbling rush on its long wide legs
heading for the front door
coraline's mouth dropped open in horror
and she stepped out of the way as the
thing clicked and scuttled past her
and out of the house running crab-like
on its too many tapping
clicking scurrying feet
she knew what it was and she knew what
it was after
she had seen it too many times in the
last few days
reaching and clutching and snatching and
popping black beetles obediently into
the other mother's mouth
five-footed crimson nailed the color
of bone it was the other mother's right
hand
it wanted the black key
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]